und jetzt ist joelina drews auch hier im
studio ich darf mich
davis ist wirklich sehr mutig habe es
gerade schon gesagt dass du dich jetzt
hier hinstellt und mit uns darüber
spricht weil gerade depressionen
essstörungen thematiken sind das ist ja
völlig egal welchen familiären
background jugendliche haben es kann
wirklich jeden treffen auch egal ob
mädchen oder junge ich persönlich habe
schon einiges auch in meinem eigenen
umfeld gehört deshalb super lasst uns
anfangen dann ging das los mit dir mit
den depressionen
also fing an ich war gerade so am anfang
meiner pubertät mit 13 jahren
und das ging tatsächlich auch einige
zeit also ich hatte da glaube ich
wirklich bis ich 17 war gut mit zu
kämpfen und dann aber als ich meinen
ersten freund hatte wurde es dann auch
langsam besser und zum glück auch
daneben
durch gespräche mit meiner mama ich hab
auch mal eine zeit lang probiert mit
therapie aber das war nicht so meins ich
bin jemand ich brauche mir relativ
schnell erfolgserlebnisse und wenn dann
die person mich erst mal kennenlernen
muss oder nicht beim grund auf kennt
dann ist es natürlich eine langwierige
sache und da haben wir dann gespräche
mit meiner mama die auch sehr analytisch
ist der deutlich besser geholfen
ja das schon dass du die familie auf
jeden fall hinter der hat es hört sich
so an 13 bis 17 ist ja auch ein
unglaublich schweres alter das
eigentlich ein alter trete ja da will
man super unbeschwert unterwegs sein und
nehmen uns da mal mit vivi war das also
für manche die vielleicht gar nicht
wissen was eine depression ist wie war
dein alltag also es war tatsächlich so
erstmal habe ich so gut wie nichts
hochkalorische mehr gegessen und habe
extrem darauf geachtet viel sport
gemacht und so und so in meiner
schlimmsten zeit war es wirklich so dass
ich einfach keinen grund gesehen habe
aufzustehen dass ich einfach keine lust
hatte irgendwas zu machen
das einzige was mich dann irgendwie
motiviert hat war dann eben meine mama
gesagt komm wir gehen jetzt zum
reiterhof ich hatte zu der zeit ein
eigenes pferd und eben die musik und
ansonsten habe ich mich auch extrem
abgekapselt damals von meinen freunden
und war auch in der schule sowieso eine
einzelgängerin aber in der zeit halt
noch mehr denn je und hab ja ebenso
einem ideal einfach hinterher gereist
und hatte dann auch zwischendurch immer
mal wieder so heulkrämpfe also es ging
wirklich dann über einen längeren
zeitraum wo ich dann wirklich jeden tag
oftmals einfach geweint habe und einfach
keinen grund gesehen habe warum ich
überhaupt hier werden wie geht es dir
jetzt also fühlst du dich jetzt wohl in
deinem leben
da konntest du total also siegen im
gegenteil also wenn ich heutzutage an
diese zeit zurück denke bin ich
eigentlich sogar sehr dankbar dafür
weil ich tatsächlich aus dieser zeit so
vieles mitgenommen habe und auch aus
dieser zeit heraus glaube ich sehr viel
reflektierender geworden bin und auch
irgendwo erwachsen so ich kann also ich
bin dankbar dafür dass ich das auch aus
eigener kraft geschafft habe und dass
ich so ein tolles umfeld um mich herum
habe so eine tolle familie und vor allem
so eine tolle mama die die auch über
gleich mit mir ja die ganzen ab sind da
uns durch gemacht mein papa aber
natürlich auch da für mich aber davon
nicht so viel mitbekommen wie sie weil
er natürlich auch sehr viel unterwegs
war
und heutzutage bin ich da komplett zum
glück raus also ich hab gar keine
probleme mehr mit mit ersten und so und
habe wirklich gelernt gut damit
umzugehen und ich meinen letzten endes
wenn man dann noch viel zu tun hat
arbeitet uns sowas hilft das auch
unheimlich viel gut damit umzugehen
das freut mich auf jeden fall für dich
hab ich glaube dass seine mama auch ganz
glücklich sein wird wenn sie das jetzt
hier sieht und von dir ja aber die
weisheit kommen wir jetzt trotzdem noch
mal auch wenn speaks und veto zu deiner
essstörung das wie dürfen wir uns das
vorstellen wie extrem war es also ich
habe in meiner
extremsten zeit auf 173 groß bin nur
noch 47 kilo gewogen wirklich nichts das
ist schon recht wenig und ich hab halt
wie ich vorhin ja ganz kurz
angeschnitten hatte nur ganz leicht
kalorischen sachen gegessen also was ich
so ein magerquark mit süßstoff oder wenn
man immer mal gekocht hat sido waren
bloß nichts mit öl anbraten sondern
immer nur mit wasser und wenn sie das
dann einmal gemacht hat sondern habe ich
mir irgendwie zum teil selber was
gekocht also ich kann mich da manche
situation noch erinnern es gibt sogar
auch noch ein videobericht im internet
meine eltern hatten jetzt in der zeit
eine hausbau serie
und da gab es auch einmal die situation
ist meine mama was gekocht hatten dann
bin ich zur seite rüber und hab mir dann
selber eine gemüsepfanne ohne öl gemacht
also so sah das dann bei mir wirklich
tagtäglich aus und ja das war zu dem
zeitpunkt auf jeden fall nicht
zuträglich wenn man so will ist das
schon ein teenager ist der dann durch
eine schwierige phase geht man weder
fisch noch fleisch ist ja das ist es
das ist einfach eine zeit wo man auf
jeden fall auch anfällig ist für sowas
aber warum hat sich das so getroffen
waren das gesellschaftliche themen oder
deine prominenten eltern was war da so
ein bisschen der grund bei dir das sei
so es sind auf jeden fall einige dinge
gewesen die dazu beigetragen haben zum
einen glaube ich war tatsächlich der
hauptgrund einfach dass ich in dieser
zeit wo man eher unsicher ist und erst
mal guckt ok wo gehört überhaupt hin ich
dann natürlich auch wusste so ja okay
ich möchte selber gerne in die
öffentlichkeit ich möchte natürlich dann
toll aussehen dazu kommt ich bin extreme
perfektionistin schon immer gewesen
und dann sieht man natürlich im
fernsehen und überall
super schöne frauen und denkt sich okay
so will ich auch aussehen
noch dazu habe ich dann eine mama die
auch noch super schön ist natürlich hat
man dem dann als teenager nach und
möchte auch so sein
und ich glaube da ist es dann auch
einfach super wichtig und das war
daneben auch der fall dass man viel
darüber redet und auch irgendwann dann
versteht dass man dass man nicht perfekt
sein muss und dass das jeder irgendwie
so seine daseinsberechtigung hat egal
wie er aussieht oder wer ist und ja also
ich bin unheimlich dankbar dass ich das
auch so im positiven dann am ende auch
für mich nutzen konnte und daraus
gelernt habe und nicht irgendwie darin
verstecken geblieben bin
das hat sich auch sehr gut an vor einem
sehr reflektierter zum abschluss
wirklich nur ein tipp von dir du bist ja
jetzt schon durchgegangen
an alle die die da gerade mittendrin
stecken
auf jeden fall wie ich gerade gesagt
habe darüber reden und genau deshalb
rede ich ja auch jetzt über dieses thema
einfach weil ich mir auch wünsche dass
eben junge menschen die vielleicht in
derselben situation stecken auch
versuchen irgendwie das für sich zu
nutzen und und auch am ende da irgendwie
was für sich heraus zu ziehen und daraus
zu lernen und nicht den kopf in den sand
zu stecken und zu sagen ich bin nichts
werden nur weil ich vielleicht nicht so
aussehe oder weil ich vielleicht
irgendwie nicht so bin wie die leute
sich das vorstellen
ich glaube oftmals ist ja auch der fall
dass viele das machen weil sie
vielleicht irgendwie auch ein
aufmerksamkeitsdefizit haben weil sie
auch schweren verhältnissen kommen oder
so und ich glaube dass es halt einfach
unheimlich wichtig dass man sich
menschen anvertraut und wenn man das
nicht gerade in der familie oder im
freundeskreis hat dass man daneben sich
wirklich professionelle hilfe sucht
danke für deine starken worte ich
wünsche dir alles gute dankeschön
dankeschön
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren